aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçu oui mais pas surpris
[Musique]
paul biya cumule plus de 39 ans de
pouvoir à la tête du cameroun à quelles
sont ses intentions pour 2025 tout le
monde sait qui aura un après biya mais
tous ceux qui sont autour du président
biya font comme si ça n'existera jamais
on a l'impression que la direction de
notre pays c'est un peu comme l'onu tout
le monde sait que ça existe tout le
monde sait qu'on est membre mais
personne n'y croit vraiment au cameroun
nous nous battons quorum pour
l'avènement de la démocratie alors on
associe le cameroun à la françafrique
mais aussi à la corruption je pense
qu'on détourne plus d'argent que le
budget d'investissement de la république
par année et chez nous nous disons que
le poisson pourrit par la tête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce lundi 14 février moscou
juge possible un règlement de la crise
russe occidentale autour de l'ukraine et
annonce même la fin de certaines
manoeuvres militaires c'est ce
qu'indique le chef de la diplomatie
russe à vladimir poutine alors que de
leur côté les etats-unis estiment
toujours qu'une invasion russe est
imminente en attendant le ballet
diplomatique se poursuit le chancelier
allemand scholl c'est à kiev pour
échanger avec le président ce dernier a
réitéré sa volonté de rentrer dans
l'otan en gage selon lui de la sécurité
de l'ukraine décryptage dans quelques
instants
on s'intéressera ensuite aux jo d'hiver
et son arrière plan diplomatique une
athlète hélène goût est au coeur d'une
polémique pour sa décision de
représenter la chine elle qui est née
aux états unis elle dit vouloir
réconcilier ces deux pays de coeur alors
la skieuse de 18 ans peut-elle réussir à
rapprocher pékin et washington au
contraire à les éloigner encore un peu
plus que blanche raison nous livrera son
analyse
les convois de la liberté veulent
désormais gagné strasbourg pour dire non
aux restrictions sanitaires la
manifestation était interdite aux abords
du parlement européen tous les axes
routiers menant vers la capitale
alsacienne sont aussi sous surveillance
après paris des milliers de véhicules
ont rallié aujourd'hui bruxelles on y
retrouvera notre envoyé spécial david
khalifa
le pass and i ter et la question des
libertés seront aussi justement au
centre de notre débat dès 21h dans notre
rubrique qu'en pensent les français nous
irons à la rencontre d'un avocat qui
s'est penché sur l'instauration de la
vaccination en france jean marc andré
estime que de nombreuses libertés ont
été bafoués au nom de la crise sanitaire
alors le temps est il venu de lâcher la
bride faut-il restaurer nos libertés on
attend aux réactions sur le conte
télégramme daté france
[Musique]
la crise ukrainienne toujours à l'heure
des discussions le chancelier allemand
olaf scholz et à kiev aujourd'hui pour
parler de ce dossier avec le président
volodymyr zelensky les deux hommes ont
donné une conférence de presse ils ont
réaffirmé le droit de l'ukraine de
décider de son avenir et encourager les
russes à poursuivre le dialogue et puis
demain direction moscou pour les choses
qui rencontrera vladimir poutine au menu
des discussions les préoccupations sur
les soupçons américain sur une possible
invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
nous voyons une grande utilité aux
discussions dans le cadre de l' os c'est
eux qui est la plateforme où tous les
états concernés peuvent se parler sur un
pied d'égalité afin de résoudre les
questions de sécurité sur la base des
principes reconnus de la coopération
européenne nous demandons à la russie de
saisir également les offres de dialogue
existantes
de nombreux dirigeants laisse légèrement
entendre que l'ukraine ne devrait pas
prendre de risque et parlait constamment
de son appartenance à l'alliance parce
que ces risques sont liés à la réaction
de la russie je pense que plus personne
ne le cache
je pense que nous devons être sincère
c'est notre décision à prendre de toute
façon
et des discussions qui continueront
cette semaine avec une réunion possible
des dirigeants de l'ue ce jeudi mais sur
le terrain comment ce ballet
diplomatique est il perçu quelles sont
les attentes de la population dans le
donbass on retrouve notre envoyé spécial
antoine claireaux ados niet bonsoir
antoine des tête à tête donc de
dirigeants politiques loin du quotidien
des premières personnes concernées
finalement comment est vécue cette
séquence diplomatique sur place
mais bon c'est fini bien alors bien
entendu les gens d'ici ils en discutent
entre eux ils en parlent ils sont au
courant de ce qui se passe mais pour la
plupart ce n'est qu'un énième
enchaînement de tractations
diplomatiques qui au final n'aura pas
d'impact réel sur leur vie quotidienne
du coup certains nous disent qu'ils
arrêtent tout bonnement de s'informer et
d'autres sont juste désabusé par la
situation actuelle comme par exemple le
yury que nous avons rencontrées sur le
marché ce matin écouter
personnellement j'essaie de ne pas
regarder la télévision
parce que je comprends que tout ce qu'on
nous raconte ne concerne que des
rencontres politiques des débats
politiques sans fin des petites choses
qui étaient aux autres des boîtes voilà
ils se sont rencontrés ils ont parlé et
alors où est le résultat le résultat
sera là quand il n'y aura plus un seul
coup de feu quand il y aura de la
stabilité économique et la prospérité
dans la région se développera alors le
résultat sera là ou presque huit ans
après le début du conflit il y en a eu
des réunions de dirigeants des réunions
de diplomates mais le constat reste le
même pas ou peu d'améliorations pour la
vie quotidienne des gens ici dans le
donbass et antoine à la douma d'état en
russie certains avancent l'idée que
moscou reconnaisse les deux républiques
autoproclamées du dombass comment cette
nouvelle et elle accueilli sur place
oui à l'heure actuelle il ne s'agit que
d'une que d'une ébauche de texte qui
doit encore être envoyés à différents
ministères pour consultation non non il
n'ya donc encore rien de fait mais pour
les autorités locales ici dans le
donbass il s'agit en quelque sorte d'une
fausse bonne idée d'une proposition qui
sera très difficile à mettre en place à
mettre en oeuvre ici dans le donbass
écouter du monde
pourquoi parce que le processus de
ministres autour duquel tout ce débat
acharné se déroule maintenant a bien été
initiée par la fédération de russie et
s'était l'initiative de la fédération de
russie qu'une résolution a été adoptée
au sein du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
sur la base de laquelle le conflit doit
être résolu pacifiquement et la
reconnaissance de ces deux territoires
ont c'est triste que ce soit pour moi
permettra à l'ukraine et à tous les pays
du format normandie de déclarer
officiellement que la russie a violé
l'accord et par conséquent les accords
des muscles cesseront d'être appliquée
oui comme on viens de l'entendre les les
autorités les responsables des
républiques autoproclamées 2-2 niet mais
aussi de lougansk sont très attachés à
l'application de ces accords de minsk
pour eux il s'agit du seul document qui
a été signé par toutes les parties
prenantes de cette crise quant à la
population elle veut juste des résultats
concrets elle veut enfin que ces
bombardements se termine et qu'elle
trouve enfin également des perspectives
d'avenir pour eux et pour leurs enfants
merci antoine au clairon en direct
depuis le dombass et de leur côté les
états unis ne cessent de répéter qu'une
invasion russe de l'ukraine pourrait
intervenir bientôt une nouvelle
accusation ce soir du porte parole du
pentagone on retrouve un autre
correspondant thomas bonnin washington
un bon soir thomas on voit thomas les
états unis n'ont de ces derniers jours
le monde d'informations alarmistes sur
une attaque imminente et dernière
information en date il y à quelques
minutes les états unis qui déclare
transférer même leur ambassade de kiev
oui c'est la dernière illustration en
date de cet alarmisme côté américain le
chef de la diplomatie américaine anthony
blinken annonce donc à l'instant le
déplacement de l'ambassade américaine de
kiev vers l'ouest de l'ukraine on
rappelle que washington exhorte les
ressortissants américains à quitter
l'ukraine au plus vite alors un peu plus
tôt ce lundi assez le porte parole du
pentagone john kirby qui sur cnn
affirmaient que la russie a renforcé ses
capacités militaires le long de la
frontière ukrainienne durant le week-end
des déclarations qui s'inscrivent dans
la lignée des messages de plus en plus
alarmistes de la part des autorités
américaines
le point d'orgue de cet alarmisme
c'était une conférence de presse
vendredi dernier à la maison blanche en
présence du conseiller à la sécurité
nationale à jake sullivan il a tenu le
discours le plus alarmiste depuis le
début de la crise du crédit en tout cas
du côté américain écouter quelques unes
de ses interventions
il est difficile d'attribuer un
pourcentage de probabilité à tout cela
nous devons penser à l'éventail de
scénarios auxquels nous sommes
confrontés et c'est notre travail d'être
prêt pour chacun d'entre eux ce que je
dirais c'est que la façon dont la russie
à constituer ses forces et les a mises
en place ainsi que les autres
indicateurs que nous avons recueillis
par le biais du renseignement nous
montre clairement qu'il ya une très
forte possibilité que la russie
choisissent d'agir militairement et
qu'il y a des raisons de croire que cela
pourrait se produire dans un délai
raisonnablement rapide
jack sullivan qui persiste puisque ce
week-end il affirmait qu'une action
militaire pourrait être lancé a très
rapidement il évoque même la possibilité
que cela se produise je cite dès cette
semaine et dans le même temps des médias
américains citent des sources des
services de renseignement pour affirmer
qu'une offensive russe contre l'ukraine
pourrait avoir lieu le mercredi 16
février c'est après mains des
allégations étonnamment précisé qu'il
laisse également sceptique un certain
nombre de diplomates européens mais tout
cela est relayée abondamment dans les
médias américains depuis des semaines on
assiste à un durcissement de ton contre
la russie de la part de la presse
américaine avec des affirmations
répétées selon lesquelles la guerre est
imminente est quasiment inéluctable avec
donc des services de renseignement qui
abreuvent les journalistes d'éléments
des éléments qui sont souvent repris
pour argent comptant alors il ya quand
même à des informations des affirmations
officielles qui sont parfois contesté
publiquement se souvient de cette scène
entre le journaliste deux épis matt lee
et le porte-parole de la diplomatie
américaine nike price le journaliste lui
demandait d'étayer les accusations
américaines selon lesquelles la russie
pourrait fomenté une attaque sous faux
drapeau pour avoir un prétexte pour
preuve envahir l'ukraine il faut aussi
préciser qu'il y à quelques voix qui
s'élèvent contre le discours alarmiste
des autorités américaines dernièrement
ses atouts le sig à barbe l'ancien
parlementaire démocrate qui évoquait
notamment les enjeux nationaux qui
peuvent aussi expliquer le
positionnement de la maison blanche sur
le dossier ukrainien il ya aussi un
certain nombre de personnes qui
rappellent le précédent des services de
renseignements et leur implication dans
la guerre en irak en 2003 en tout cas
pour finir on voit que ce discours
alarmiste semble moins imprimés auprès
des plus jeunes américains selon un
sondage une majorité des américains de
18 à 29 ans souhaiterait que les
etats-unis se tiennent éloignés des
discussions entre la russie et l'ukraine
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington alors pourquoi les etats-unis
parlent d'une attaque russe en ukraine
imminente sur quels éléments concrets ce
bastille les américains sont-ils en
pleine guerre de l'information place au
débat avec nos invités
[Musique]
et
avec nous sur ce plateau pour en parler
geraldo ollivier journaliste chercheur
associé à lips bonsoir gérer olivier
merci d'être avec nous à nos côtés
également eugène berg ancien diplomate
bonsoir j'aime bien merci d'être là
alors tout malgré l annonce bonsoir
malgré l'annoncé par moscou de la fin de
certains je dis bien certains exercices
militaires moscou qui semble-t-il calme
le jeu aujourd'hui le porte parole du
pentagone affirme ce soir que la russie
a encore renforcé son dispositif
militaire aux frontières de l'ukraine au
cours du du week-end c'est vrai qu'on a
du mal à suivre gérald olivier peut-être
que vous qui connaissez bien les états
unis pouvez vous nous éclairer sur quoi
se basent washington pour affirmer ce
type d'information leurs a priori ils
ont des renseignements qui sont assez
précis puisque comme le rappelait votre
reporter de quelques minutes ils ont
même la date de cette invasion à
mercredi 16 février ils n'ont pas
communiqué enfin certains éléments de
ces renseignements ont été communiqués à
certains organes de presse dont la
société de presse et autres mais on n'a
pas véritablement de détails par contre
il est évident que d'un point de vue
diplomatique et d'un point de vue pour
la maison blanche ou même pour le
département d'état ils ont tout intérêt
à je dirais jouer les alarmistes c'est à
dire que s'il s'avérait que les choses
tournent mal à la frontière ukrainienne
et il aurait tout loisir de dire on vous
avait prévenus et poutine apparaîtrait
comme l'agresseur si par contre il y a
des escalades ils auront tout loisir de
dire notre discours a été entendu et
donc nous avons eu gain de cause donc
ils auront gagné sur les deux tableaux
c'est un point de vue qui permet d'une
certaine façon en même temps de m
vladimir poutine et la russie un petit
peu plus sous le spotlight est de faire
en sorte que s'il avait eu l'intention
ce qui n'a jamais été prouvée mais s'il
avait une intention véritable d'envahir
l'ukraine d'y réfléchir un petit peu à
deux fois avant de le faire mais sur le
plan diplomatique c'est du gagnant
gagnant pour eux que de faire monter la
tension et j'aime bien vous avez le la
même analyse que gérald olivier du
gagnant gagnant pour les états unis au
mieux ils auront servi à faire la paix
au pire enfin ce que nous explique et
geraldo l'idée
bon c'est une interprétation c'est vrai
mais je crois que les américains
faisant adoptant cette attitude 1 hier
j'écoutais la télévision russe il s'en
amuse il se dit jouer c'est ce pourquoi
pas le 22 2 22 ça serait fantastique ce
serait vraiment un chiffre rond bon
soyons sérieux ça fait longtemps que ça
dure moi j'aimerais apporter un autre
une autre un élément au débat il faut
pas oublier que la russie est le premier
exportateur de pétrole elle fournit 40%
du gaz et finalement les états unis en
lançant cette espèce de de pressions
psychologiques et en alarmant mais ils
font monter les prix le brent et à 100
dollars aujourd'hui le gaz a multiplié
par 4 et lire la russie est en train
d'engranger
énormément des milliards de dollars
alors si j'étais américain bravo ils
sont en train de renforcer l'arsenal
financier de ce qu'ils appellent leur et
demi donc là aussi leur stratégie est un
peu à courte vue alors évidemment ça
c'est qu'un élément l'autre élément
effectivement vous la personne n'a
mentionné tout à l'heure j'ai écouté
quand même monsieur lavrov à la radio
russe matin à face après midi il a une
discussion avec ans avec monsieur
charles de gaulle mise la défense et
monsieur poutine d'ailleurs maintenant
il ya une expression à moscou le format
micro ou macro c'est à dire une grande
table et monsieur là j'ai entendu
monsieur poutine a demandé à son
ministre voyez c'est ouvert est ce que
vraiment on a épuisé les possibilités de
dialogue est bien le chef
le vétéran la diplômée à des vétérans la
diplomatie mondiale a répondu avec son
solide bon sens en tant que diplomate je
dirais non et je pèse mes mots il a dit
non les possibilités peuvent être
prolongé et élargi
élargissez justement
je crois dans la tente de l'arrivée du
chancelier fédéral hall of fame ce coup
et on verra si effectivement ils seront
élargis donc il ya tous ces ce battage
médiatique d'une invasion mais il ya
également la négociation qui se prolonge
et peut-être qu'il va même s'élargir on
verra effectivement on l'a mentionné
tout à l'heure ses mots plutôt rassurant
cette main en tout cas ce geste tendu de
de sergueï lavrov justement on parlait
de désinformation ce battage médiatique
vous venez de le dire aux jeunes bergues
on va regarder certains titres de la
presse américaine a clairement alarmiste
à l'instar de son gouvernement je vous
en laisse découvrir certains cnn un très
proche euros c'est un peu tôt des
démocrates du gouvernement la russie
encerclent l'ukraine sur trois côtés
voici d'où une invasion pourraient être
lancés alors etienne c'est carrément
doux l'invasion va être lancé en
politique au les états unis alerte sur
la possibilité d'une guerre imminente en
ukraine ce soir gérald olivier on
apprend également que l'ambassade des
états unis est transféré dans une autre
ville que kiev
il ya également cette guerre de la
désinformation ça passe par là les
médias sont-ils entre guillemets
complice où ils ont des informations que
nous n'avons pas nous ça fait quand même
un certain temps que les médias
américains enfin ce qu'on appelle les
mainstream media cnn ont fait partie et
bicici billets mais cette bi sinon tout
à fait sont relativement clément
vis-à-vis du président byden et de la
politique démocrate et si vous avez une
chaîne qui met en garde un petit peu
contre 7 je dirais guerre de la
désinformation c'est fox news
aujourd'hui où vous avez un certain
nombre d'intervenants qui essayent de
raison garder comme on dit et c'est
d'ailleurs sur cette chaîne que tu si
gabart dont on a parlé sept
représentants démocrates de hawaï
s'étaient exprimés maintenant ce qu'il
faut comprendre aussi c'est que il ya un
intérêt je dirais en termes de politique
intérieure joe biden a bien besoin d'une
distraction et inscriptions comment les
élections les élections de mi mandat et
puis vous avez un convoi de la liberté
dont on parle beaucoup au canada il
était question qui est un convoi de la
liberté aux états unis on à la question
de la frontière au texas et de la
frontière avec le mexique qui a été
bafouée considérablement tout au long de
l'année et un certain nombre d'élus
républicains bar proche des démocrates
de se soucier beaucoup plus de la
frontière ukrainienne que de la
frontière avec le mexique scanner paix
ce qui n'est pas totalement logique
pourtant il ya aussi beaucoup de
républicains qui souhaitent défendre
l'ukraine ardemment en espace
il ya deux positions si vous voulez il
ya une position qui va de toute façon en
effet défendre l'ukraine mais vous avez
malgré tout une position qui n'est pas
favorable à ce que la situation dégénère
et il n'est pas à mon avis même dans
l'intérêt des démocrates qu'une telle
situation dégénère par contre utiliser
cette situation pour distraire un petit
peu l'opinion de fès économiques et
autres qui ne sont pas forcément
favorables à monsieur bart hayden ça on
comprend très bien pourquoi ils veulent
le faire
eugène bergues
joe biden n'est pas le seul il ya aussi
jean yves le drian qui s'y met on a on a
toujours reconnu d'aider des positions
assez sévère envers la russie jean yves
le drian qui dit ce soir rejoindre la
position des états unis il estime que
tous les éléments sont réunis pour une
offensive militaire forte de la russie
en ukraine il rajoute tout de même rien
d'un tic un petit peu plus prudent que
le président russe ait pris une décision
il est manipulé jean yves le drian ou
lui aussi participe finalement à cette
stratégie qui pourrait peut-être faire
plier moscou comme nous l'expliqué
gérald olivier tout à l'heure
bon je sais pas je pense que tout
bonnement il ya peut-être une
répartition des rôles au président
macron qui est en campagne entrée
campagne électorale donc manifestement
daloa moscou il prend un peu de voix
incertain chrome os coup il faut pas
oublier chacun jour est en campagne
électorale olaf schulze ils essaient
sondages ont baissé de derrière la cd ou
donc là aussi douillet il n'y a pas que
le côté interne politique interne 16
unis a chez nous mais je crois que
l'essentiel c'est qu'ils se répartissent
les rôles disons un à monsieur le drian
qui est plus âgée de 2 joue un peu le
rôle des pères fouettards si je peux en
plissés expression un peu galvaudé et
emmanuel macron de jouer le messager de
la paix du médiateur dicton du bon il ya
le bon et le méchant fin ça fait partie
un peu du western bon mais au-delà de ça
je crois que et bien chacun prend des
assurances des contres assurance mais ça
devient évidemment la sens puisque ça
fait des semaines que ça dure on en est
au 4e à 3e acte il faut absolument que
ça se dit ça se résolvent jeu on à dire
plusieurs reprises moi même
personnellement il faudrait que dans les
dix jours à 15 jours on a quelque chose
ou là effectivement entrera dans la
possibilité de tir mais encore une fois
bon et ce qui aura invasion est ce
qu'ils auraient incursion sk provocation
vous faisait allusion
la douma qui propose de reconnaître les
républiques autoproclamées
ce qui veut pas dire que ça sera
ratifiée par poutine séguin ce n'est
qu'à la moyenne pression de plus puisque
les états unis font pression et bien les
russes font pression aussi ils ont comme
leurs opinions publiques ils ont quand
même leur préoccupation il faut quand
même prendre il n'y a pas que vladimir
poutine même tout puissant qu'il est qu
qui est le vrai pouvoir décisionnel et
quand même d'autres forces d'autres
intérêts qu'il faut ménager donc là
aussi il ya un jeu qui est complexe mais
l'essentiel c'est qu'il faut passer aux
choses sérieuses c'est à dire en
négociation et la lavrov équipe qui
n'est pas mon sens qui ne prenant jamais
des mots hasard c'est vraiment un
orfèvre il a dit qu'il faut je répète
qu'il faut prolonger élargir les
négociations
donc là il ya quand même à grains
d'espoir et j'espère ce gr donnera
naissance à une fleur comme dans l'air à
la saint-valentin qu'on pourra offrir à
nos compagnes
on voit ça ce qui est très important à
souligner je suis relativement d'accord
c'est que faut pas perdre de vue la
raison réelle de ce qui se passe en ce
moment en ukraine dire que le sujet
c'est pas l'ukraine le sujet c'est le
temps ce qui ce qui fait peur j'admire
poutine ce n'est pas du tout l'ukraine
c'est la position de l'otan et l'idée de
la nuit poutine en fait c'est d'obtenir
une sorte de garantie que l'ukraine ne
deviendra jamais un membre de l'otan si
vous prenez la position américaine la
position des démocrates au contraire
c'est de justifier la nécessité de la
poursuite de l'existence de l'otan je
rappelle qu'il ya quelques années en
campagne électorale le candidat donald
trump avait remis en cause la nécessité
de l'otan et avait avait suscité avait
émis l'idée d'un rapprochement avec la
russie le président macro nuit même à un
moment a dit que l'otan était totalement
obsolète cérébrale voilà en mort
cérébrale c'était trop qui avait dès
qu'ils étaient obsolètes alors attendez
pas ce que parce que c'est vrai que ce
que ce que vient de nous dire gerald de
milliers c'est très intéressant parce
que au rejet nous donner la parole aux
jeunes des grands dans quelques instants
volodymyr zelensky aujourd'hui
évidemment à souffler sur les braises ce
n'est pas une surprise mais il a redit à
l'occasion de sa rencontre avec dow
jones qui voulait que son pays
appartient à l'otan que ça garantir et
notre sécurité à la sécurité de de
l'ukraine quand on sait que c'est la
ligne rouge russe voilà c'est pas non
plus de nature à calmer les choses
jeanne berthe ça
bah je sais pas d'où tu n'es pas cher
c'est un fort monsieur machin tu vas y
moi j'entends du bond de la conférence
de presse à l'après midi entre volet des
miens silent ski et olaf scholz il a
réitéré sa main directement à oui
absolument absolument ah bon parce que
moi j'ai eu l'information à la radio
russe le quai comme sérieuse qui a dit
qu'effectivement un peu le contraire
qu'en disant qu' on mettrait pas ça en
avant comme objectif et son ambassadeur
à londres ça fait l'objet d'une
polémique il a dit justement
l'ambassadeur ukrainien allant dans dix
ans écoutez c'est pas le moment de soul
elle prône de l'otan ça peut attendre et
ou alors il s'est fait taper sur les
doigts mais on peut pas et sur un ballon
d'essai on lui a demandé de dire ça pour
ensuite le contrarier donc il ya aussi
un jeu multiple à kiev entre les
différentes mais enfin je vous écoute si
vous avez vraiment entendu sort de la
gmac l'hymne japonais vivent hors bon on
a compris la même chose well soon et moi
j'ai lu la même dépêche et j'ai vu le
même extrait de conférence de presse
mais on comprend très bien pourquoi
l'ukraine veut devenir membre de l'otan
ils ont raison c'est un véritable
parapluie par contre c'est vrai que ce
n'était pas réellement sur la table
c'est là où d'ailleurs il faut regarder
un petit peu la politique un peu plus
loin parce que malgré tous les exercices
militaires russes ils sont réels le
positionnement des troupes russes à la
frontière ukrainienne il est réel les
exercices que sont en train de mener
biélorusses et russes en commun ils sont
réels et donc il ya eu de la part de la
russie une décision volontaire de faire
monter la pression et je pense que là on
a une attitude qui à mon avis a tiré
certaines leçons du désastre et de la
débâcle américaine en afghanistan où
l'administration américaine est apparue
très très faible ce qui a donné à dali
moeurs poutine un prétexte d' essayer
d'en profiter là les américains ont
réussi je dirais relativement habilement
d'un point de vue diplomatique a
renversé un petit peu la situation
justement en faisant monter la pression
mais je pense que cette crise aurait pu
ou réduits ne jamais se produire en tout
cas washington compte offrir jusqu'à un
milliard de dollars de garanties de
crédit à kiev on vient de l'apprendre et
l instant également la russie n'envahira
pas l'ukraine sauf si on nous prouve à
aucun c'est ce que dit l'ambassadeur
russe auprès de l'union européenne alors
ça c'est toujours la même chose sauf si
on nous provoquent justement et bien
voilà qui provoque qui s'est toujours la
question dans cette affaire aux jeunes
berg parce qu'une une flamme et vite
allumé à la frontière où il ya des
militaires de part et d'autre tout de
même on le rappelle quand même
oui non c'est vrai il faut pas oublier
que les russes étaient leurs thèses
constant de dire que vous les
occidentaux vous nous pointer du doigt
parce qu'on masse et réseaux mais vous
ne pointe pas du doigt l'armée
ukrainienne et les extrémistes
ukrainiens comme has ofpra plein du
secteur qui est prêt à prendre de force
d'une basse et le gams ça aussi ça fait
partie quand même il faut ouvrir un peu
les yeux même si c'est disproportionné
mais donc les occidentaux en livrant des
armes offensives les jav l'un des
hélicoptères des tanks vous armée
l'armée ukrainienne qui enfin où une
partie des forces craignait qui voudrait
employer la force puisque boutines le
dif
dans la constitution ukrainienne ilia à
l'est la russie est un ennemi puis 2
reprendra en fin de texte quasi
constitution on va reprendre la crimée
par la force donc tout ça alors même si
on le prend une propagande pour pour
d'egypte des déclarations c'est quand
même des menaces donc il faut il faut
j'ai toujours dit il faut que les
occidentaux aussi demandent un fief
d'appliquer les accords de minsk et de
ne pas jeter de l'huile sur le feu c'est
ça la désescalade elle doit être j'avais
dit elle doit être proportionnée et
simultanées alors évidemment s'il ya un
effort ukrainien qui sera suivi d'un
défaut russes ont contrôlé dans une
escalade malheureusement
une semaine après le voyage du président
macron à moscou on a pratiquement fait
15 mm alors que venait faire un maître
mais la presse dominicale instant on
apprend que l'ukraine a été informée on
en sait un peu plus sur ce fameux
mercredi l'ukraine a été informée
qu'elle serait attaquée par la russie le
mercredi 16 février
c'est ce qu'annonce le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky et c'est
cnn évidemment qui donne cette
information
oui vous inspire pas en avant pour enfin
pouvoir revenir à votre toute première
question on n'a pas eu connaissance de
du renseignement précis qui permet d'en
arriver à ces notions mais c'est vrai
que ça passe par l'ukraine par le
président ukrainien qui volent à sauver
ce qu à cnn c'était également une
demande du président ukrainien qui la
semaine dernière avait émis une
déclaration en disant si les états unis
ont des renseignements précis concernant
une une attaque possible qu'ils nous les
communiquent donc à mon avis et c'est la
réponse à cette question mais on n'a pas
le contenu de ce renseignement précis ça
nous rappelle la guerre en irak
peut-être quand on a demandé
désespérément des preuves d'armes de
destruction massive qu'on n'a jamais
donné ou où mon esprit ces gars
totalement on n'est pas tout à fait là
j'emmène il ya moins sur la question tu
avais lancé une guerre sur la base où il
est d'un mensonge ou ce qui y est ce qui
est préoccupant c'est ce que vous et que
ce que vous évoquez à quelques minutes
c'est à dire une étincelle qui viendrait
de quelque part ou peut-être même une
fausse information ou une fausse attaque
qui pourrait donner cause à un prétexte
pour qui une réalisation derrière etc
etc c'est ça qui est le plus dangereux
c'est en tout cas évidemment j'aime bien
le mot de la fin pour vous
bah écoutez c'est un peu contradictoire
parce que monsieur zielinski a dit vous
faites une hystérie sur yon le calme
alors le mot de la fin je vais le donner
au général de gaulle c'est en pleine
crise de berlin l'ambassadeur soviétique
étaient les lois en disant si vous ne
savez pas et bien droit à une guerre et
on va alors le général de gaulle s'est
levé monsieur l'ambassadeur nous
mourrons ensemble
donc voilà je crois qu'il faut garder la
tête froide et il faut il faut décompter
les choses on verra le 16 et pourquoi
pas 17 ont pas 18 bon c'est sérieux je
crois que l'on s'est pas lieu de faire
l'humour mais je crois que c'est les
historiens auront beaucoup à dire parce
que là on arrive comme disent les russes
à degré d'hystérie peu connu dans les
relations internationales
on négocie en même temps on dit on va
attaquer quoi c'est quelque chose qui
est
ça va au delà de l'entendement donc vous
qu'on verra bon attendons au lof charles
ski alors prudents qui a consulté angela
merkel qui est aussi qu'elle connaît
très bien vladimir poutine et les
allemands paient ils ont quand même
beaucoup d'intérêt on n'a pas eu le
temps d'en parler aujourd'hui on en
reparlera peut-être deux ou trois quatre
jours là aussi c'est quand même une
mission très importante et encore une
fois qui est fait en pleine coordination
entre l'elysée puis le bund scan sera et
quoi là aussi donc l'europe revient et
c'est très intéressant vous allusion à
l'irak vous savez les trois pays france
allemagne russie se sont opposées à
l'intervention des états unis et l'irak
est ce cette trouille cas alors elle
n'existe pas encore mais il n'est pas
impossible qu'ils aient une volonté de
lui donner une petite vie une petite
flamme en disant oui il ya quand même
trois pays qui sont les trois grands
pays européens la russie l'allemagne et
la france qui peuvent faire quelque
chose alors que les anglo saxons eux ils
jettent de l'huile sur le feu ils sont
les alarmistes ils veulent reconstituer
l'otan donc là aussi il ya cet aspect
qu'il faut c'est pas uniquement comme
l'ukraine
c'est toute cette géopolitique
européenne et mondiale qui est en jeu
donc voyez c'est quelque chose je crois
qui fondent et le conscient et encore
analysé dans un dans un cadre plus large
plus large ici d'où le parallèle
évidemment puisque la situation n'est
pas comparable
malgré tout des américains font monter
l'hystérie parce qu'il met en garde
contre une invasion possible là il n'est
pas question pour l'instant d'une
quelconque intervention américaine en
ukraine ça c'est pas du tout le sujet
voilà on en n'est pas là c'est tombé
d'accord on est on est bien d'accord
merci à tous les deux jeunes berg
général de l'idée d'avoir été avec nous
et lingus est un nom qui ne vous dit
peut-être rien mais à 18 ans seulement
cette jeune femme est devenue médaillée
d'or il ya une semaine aux jeux
olympiques d'hiver de pékin mais au delà
du graal la skieuse acrobatique
américano chinoises se retrouve au coeur
d'une polémique qui dépasse le cadre
sportif en toile de fond les relations
diplomatiques entre ces deux pays de
coeur adrien fonteneau
un double cork 1620
c'est peut être un détail pour vous mais
pour elle ça veut dire beaucoup en un
saut ayling où est passé de l'ombre à la
lumière des rampes de ski chinoise au
feu des critiques américaine
eileen goût né aux états unis qui vit à
san francisco et va intégrer
l'université stanford cet automne entre
dans une nouvelle réalité où des
millions de ses compatriotes qui ne se
souciait pas de sa citoyenneté vont
maintenant se demander pourquoi elle
concourt pour le pays où sa mère est née
et non le sien
aïe lingua obtenu sa médaille d'or et la
chine son pion mais pas sûr qu'elle
sache réellement à quel point elle est
utilisée elle n'a que 18 ans il est
facile de comprendre pourquoi la chine
veut qu'elle soit le visage des jeux
olympiques un visage extrêmement
commercialisables qui fait oublier aux
gens comment le gouvernement chinois
fonctionnent vraiment chinoise par sa
mère mais élevé selon le modèle
américain de son père eileen goût a vu
son choix sportif être saluée par la
presse d'état chinoise
même si elle rejette toute récupération
politique
[Musique]
j'ai toujours été reconnaissants envers
les états unis et l'équipe américaine
ils ont été un soutien important et je
leur en serai toujours reconnaissante
mais cela vaut aussi pour l'équipe
chinoise qui m'a beaucoup soutenu en ce
sens je pense que le sport est vraiment
moyen d'unir les gens ce n'est pas une
question de nationalité
ce sujet ne peut être utilisée pour
diviser les gens
j'utilise ma voix pour créer autant de
changements positifs que possible et
pour ce prêt à écouter ce que j'estime
pertinents je sais que j'ai bon coeur et
que les raisons pour lesquelles j'ai
pris mes décisions sont fondées sur un
intérêt commun plus grands
un intérêt que la chine ne reconnaît pas
non plus totalement la loi chinoise sur
la citoyenneté n'autorise pas la double
nationalité et un article sur le symbole
eileen goût a été censuré par le pouvoir
chinois mais pour le public
l'essentiel est ailleurs
la nationalité américaine dai bingguo ne
me dérange pas et je pense même qu'avec
sa double nationalité chinoise elle a
vraiment un impact très positif sur la
motivation du peuple chinois et la
promotion du sport en chine
je pense que l'état actuel du pays va
attirer davantage d'adolescents de
nationalité étrangère désireux de voir
le développement de la chine à revenir
comme l'a fait à ealing ou
porter au plus haut les couleurs de la
chine sur la planète sportive ayling ou
en aura encore l'occasion la skieuse
acrobatique peut encore ajouté deux
médailles à son palmarès olympique mais
relancé aussi une polémique au delà du
sportif
et pour en parler nous sommes avec un
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir club
blanchemaison les ressources ou d'être
avec nous et line vu la snowboardeuse
dont peut-elle rapprocher la chine et
les états unis comme elle le
souhaiterait ou au contraire les
éloigner encore un petit peu plus je ne
crois pas que cet épisode constr
contribuer à approcher vraiment les
états unis de la chine l'hostilité entre
l'italie et la chine
et
elle est bien connue la chine est en
train de poursuivre sa croissance
économique pour un jour prendre la place
les états unis et devenir la puissance
numéro un dans le monde donc il ya une
rivalité qui fait que l'élève est
beaucoup plus important pour les états
unis de contenir la chine par tous les
moyens
simplement ce qui se passe c'est que
hélène goût est né à san francisco d'un
père américain et d'une mère chinoise
qui est d'ailleurs une femme d'affaires
chinoise aux états unis et que jusqu'à
il ya trois ans elle faisait ses
compétitions sous le drapeau américain
et puis qu'il ya trois ans elle a choisi
avec les organisations sportives de le
faire sous le drapeau chinois la
république populaire de chine c'est son
choix et et ça ne contribue pas
véritablement à au rapprochement entre
les etats-unis et la chine peut être
même sacré des frictions additionnel
parce que le public américain peut se
demander pourquoi elle a déserté les
états unis pour se placer sous le
drapeau chinois alors d'autant plus
qu'il ya cette fameuse loi sur la
citoyenneté en chine qui n'autorise pas
la double nationalité alors que
va-t-elle faire renoncer à la
nationalité américaine mais à 18 ans
elle a beaucoup de sagesse puisqu'elle a
dit lorsque je suis aux états unis et je
me sens pleinement américaine lorsque je
suis en chine je me sens pleinement
chinoise c'est l'explication alors je
pense que elle est aujourd'hui une très
grande vedette de les jeux olympiques
d'hiver de pékin est par conséquent
pékin a bien vu l'intérêt qu'il y avait
à la cultiver et à la faire concourir
sous le drapeau chinois et que les
chinois sont des pragmatiques
s'il faut lui donner la nationalité
chinoise au moins sur le plan sportif
parce que ça ne veut pas dire qu'elle
l'a sur tous les plans eh bien on lui
donne la nationalité chinoise pour
gagner les compétitions et rapporter des
médailles d'or de son côté n'est ce pas
avant tout aussi une décision peut-être
financière totalement la maman et femme
d'affaires chinoise aux états unis et
tous les médias expliquent que les
grands sponsors notamment les maisons de
luxe lvmh vu que les recycler quelques
autres la banque de chine considère qu'
il n' goût et est un très très bon un
très bon investissement je crois que
l'année dernière en 2021 elle a pu
recueillir environ 30 millions de
dollars au titre de des sponsors de deux
compétitions qui n'étaient pas les jeux
olympiques alors qu'est ce que ça va
être pour les jeux olympiques donc là
dessus en effet il n'y a pas de
questions toutes les grandes entreprises
considèrent que le marché chinois est
tellement énorme que ça vaut la peine
d'investir dans cette image dans hélène
goût est envoyée derrière vous que
beaucoup de sponsors ont déjà succombé à
la tentation effectivement d'utiliser
ces bombes à eau en mannequin alors sur
le volet diplomatique
clos blanchemaison pour cette édition
des jeux de nombreux pays on le sait
comme les états unis le royaume uni
l'australie le canada ou le japon ont
décidé de n'envoyer aucun responsable
politique dans le but de dénoncer les
atteintes aux droits de l'homme et la
répression envers les minorités
musulmanes des ouigours legio toujours
décidément à l'arrière-plan de la
diplomatie mais c'est pas nouveau ça a
toujours été le cas en 1936 la question
s'est posée pour les jo de berlin qui
était
organisée pour célébrer le pouvoir
d'hitler
ensuite il ya eu d'autres gio qui ont
été boycottées en russie aux etats-unis
et ailleurs mais c'est un boycott
politique tant qu'il s'agit d'un boycott
politique c'est un symbole dans le fond
il n'y a pas de délégations officielles
gouvernementales
ça n'est pas très grave encore que la
france avait décidé d'envoyer sa
ministre des sports qui je prend
malheureusement été déclarée positive au
que vie de 19 ans n'a pas pu s'y rendre
mais politiquement le symbole était
qu'il y aurait eu un membre du
gouvernement français présents à
l'ouverture des jeux alors je crois pour
le reste est bien et ce qui est
important c'est que les sportifs
puisse faire la compétition qui serait
très grave c'est qu'on empêche des
sportifs d'aller concourir à des jeux
sous prétexte de busines politique merci
beaucoup claude blanche raison d'avoir
été avec nous et les jo de pékin marquée
également par l'entrée en compétition de
la russie camila vallejo à la jeune
patineuse testé positif à un produit
dopant en décembre dernier a finalement
été autorisé par la tasse à concourir
une décision qui suscite de nombreuses
réactions notamment de la part des états
unis les explications à moscou de notre
correspondante maëlys d'estrées
il semblerait que les etats-unis se
saisisse de la moindre occasion pour
infliger à la russie des avanies en tous
genres la sphère camila vallejo en est
une nouvelle preuve pour rappel la
patineuse russe de 15 ans a été testée
positive un produit dopant en décembre
un résultat communiqué celui février
soit un jour après sa victoire partagée
avec ses compatriotes dans l'épreuve par
équipes aux jeux olympiques de pékin ce
14 février le tribunal arbitral du sport
a autorisé camila vallejo a continué les
jeux olympiques de pékin une décision
qui déçoit le comité olympique américain
les athlètes ont le droit de savoir s'il
concours sur un pied d'égalité
malheureusement aujourd'hui ce droit est
bafoué cela semble être un nouveau
chapitre dans l'histoire du mépris
systémique et généralisée de la russie
pour le sport sans dopage
pour certains médias américains
toutefois ce scandale révèle avant tout
les erreurs telles antidopage mondiale
la sphère camila vallejo a est un
réquisitoire contre le système
antidopage pas contre elle l'histoire
avec vallier va à démasquer une fois de
plus l' agence mondiale antidopage avec
sa toxicologie de mauvaise qualité
ces persécutions arbitraire et ses
spirales juridique sans fin les obsédés
du sang pur et les rivaux de la russie
long au rang de crimes mondiale et la
emma et le comité international
olympique ont plongé vallier va et tout
le monde dans l'incertitude avec ce
processus de suspension à plusieurs
niveaux c'est bien la championne
olympique russe qui souffre la première
de cette affaire ses jours ont été très
compliqué pour moi et je suis à cours
d'émotion je suis heureuse mais je suis
fatigué émotionnel donc ce sont des
larmes de bonheur et un peu de chagrin
en même temps je suis bien sûr heureuse
d'être jeux olympiques et de représenter
notre pays un facteur pris en compte par
le tribunal arbitral du sport qui
considère que suspendre l'athlète
mineurs avant d'avoir examiner le fond
de la sphère lui causerait un préjudice
je cite irréparable d'autant plus qu'on
peut s'interroger sur les raisons du
laps de temps écoulé entre le 25
décembre date du contrôle anti-dopage la
patineuse et le 8 février date où le
résultat positif a été communiqué par un
laboratoire accrédité par l'agencé
mondiale antidopage alors que ce genre
de résultat doit être fournie dans un
délai de 20 jours et quand bien même la
jeune athlète aurait effectivement
consommé de la trimétazidine un
médicament utilisé notamment pour
soulager les angines de poitrine est
interdit par la m a depuis 2014 de
nombreux médecins russes mais aussi
américains estiment que cette substance
n'a aucun effet sur les performances
sportives au milieu de cette tourmente
camila vallejo peut malgré tout compter
sur le soutien de son pays y compris
celui du kremlin
nous soutenons notre camila vallejo sans
limite absolument et quoi qu'il arrive
nous appelons tout le monde à la
soutenir et 10 ans à camilla camilla ne
cache pas ton visage tu es russe va
fièrement que ce soit et surtout
participent aux compétitions et triomphe
de tout tes concurrents
même si la russie se réjouit de voir la
jeune prodige continuer les chiots il
faudra attendre plusieurs mois avant de
connaître les conséquences de ce test
positif pour camila vallejo a et le
sport russe le comité international
olympique a annoncé qu'il attendrait que
le fond de l'affairé soit tranchée pour
remettre leurs médailles aux vainqueurs
de l'épreuve de patinage artistique par
équipes de leur côté les états unis ont
d'ores et déjà brandi la menace d'une
loi adoptée en 2020 ce qui leur permet
de poursuivre toute personne impliquée
dans une affaire de dopage dans une
compétition internationale il semblerait
bien que la controversée
extraterritorialité de la loi américaine
ne se satisfassent plus de la seule
politique et veillent désormais aussi
s'aventurer dans le domaine sportif au
grand dam d'autres nations
dans le reste de l'actualité une réunion
pour évoquer l'avenir de notre planète
depuis ce matin 195 p il se penche sur
les impacts dévastateurs du
réchauffement climatique des discussions
en vue d'approuver un nouveau rapport du
giec sur la question les précisions de
rémy savary
face aux changements de température il
est parfois difficile de trouver la
bonne tenue avec le réchauffement
climatique les moyennes de saison ne
semble plus vouloir dire grand chose
depuis ce lundi
195 pays sont réunis objectif valider le
futur rapport du giec
ce dernier aborde la façon de se
préparer aux impacts de ces changements
lors de l'ouverture de ce rassemblement
le président des experts climat de l'onu
hosoo lee s'est montré particulièrement
alarmiste les besoins pour ce rapport
sur les impacts du réchauffement et la
façon dont s'y préparait n'ont jamais
été aussi importants parce que les
enjeux n'ont jamais été aussi élevé en
un peu plus d'un siècle de développement
économique consacrée aux énergies
fossiles la planète a vu sa température
moyenne augmente aidé 1,1 degré celsius
par rapport à l'ère préindustrielle un
marathon d'autodestruction qu'il devient
peu à peu une course contre la montre
les pays les villes les entreprises les
investisseurs et les acteurs individuels
les consommateurs doivent transformer ce
premier pas en sprint si nous ne voulons
pas dépasser +1 5° ce rapport est
capital pour aider les décideurs
mondiaux a dessiné les réponses aux
impacts climatiques
un véritable combat pour la survie
générale dans lequel un co-auteur de ce
rapport souligne l'importance de
s'adapter tout dixième de degré est
important à gagner dans la lutte contre
le changement climatique
toute âme et la réduction des gaz à
effet de serre les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et pourtant aussi à
gagner donc c'est bien mieux d'être à
2,5 2,6 qui a 3 à 3,1 même si on dépasse
l'objectif des 2 degrés ce qui
évidemment c'est un catastrophique mais
même si on dépasse tous les efforts
qu'on peut faire dès aujourd'hui sont
bons à prendre
depuis le début de l'année des
phénomènes météorologiques extrêmes ont
été aperçues partout dans le monde au
mois de janvier des incendies ont
sévèrement touché l'état américain du
colorado en raison de la sécheresse
un phénomène
mêlés à des épisodes neigeux
l'impact du réchauffement climatique se
veut aussi de plus en plus coûteux en
2021 les dix plus grosses catastrophes
naturelles ont coûté plus de 170
milliards de dollars selon les ong
britannique christian aid
désormais les 195 pays ont deux semaines
pour établir un rapport définitif
conclusions le 28 février
j - 55 avant le premier jour de la
présidentielle à droite valérie pécresse
s'explique après son grand meeting très
critiqué au zénith de paris ce devait
être ce devait être le rendez vous de la
relance pour permettre à la candidate
des républicains de distancer ses
adversaires sur sa droite sur le fond la
candidate a été vivement interpellé pour
avoir évoqué à l'instar d'eric zemmour
le grand remplacement sur la forme elle
s'est montré souvent eu à l'est selon
les critiques devant son public on les
écoute
si l'objectif c'est d'avoir un orateur
alors je pense qu'il y à meilleur que
moi si l'objectif c'est d'avoir une
fâcheuse alors je suis la meilleure
candidate par ailleurs sur les meetings
il y a eu un candidat qui a eu du mal à
faire des meetings au début de sa
carrière politique il s'appelait
emmanuel macron pour revenir sur cette
actualité politique nous sommes avec
eric revel éditorialistes rt france
bonsoir eric revel merci d'être avec
nous avons décidément un mauvaise
séquence qui se poursuit pour valérie
pécresse critiqué sur la forme mais
aussi sur le fond parfois oui alors je
regardais il ya une citation de victor
hugo quand on sort un peu dans tous les
sens mais là qui colle pile poil si
j'ose dire c'est la phrase suivante la
forme c'est le fond qui remonte à la
surface donc en fait on peut pas
dissocier la forme du fonds et c'est
vrai que valérie pécresse dimanche à son
meeting parisien du zénith a marqué les
esprits mais sans doute pas dans le bon
sens on l'attendait meilleur oratrice on
l'attendait avec des éléments
programmatiques un peu plus fort on a eu
le sentiment par moments et une partie
de l'auditoire ou des gens qui
regardaient ce meeting en était un peu
mal à l'aise parce qu'on avait
l'impression qu'elle qu'elle enchaînait
des phrases de communicants collées les
unes derrière les autres ce qui lui a
pas rendu service peut-être qu'il aurait
été préférable je n'ai pas de conseils
boon aurait été préférable qu'elles
ciblent davantage par exemple emmanuel
macron qui va rentrer en campagne et
qu'elle essaie d'installer un espèce de
face à face entre lui entre elle et le
chef de l'état qui lorsqu'il serait
rentré en campagne aurait été de obligé
de répondre à la lecture par exemple du
bilan qu'elle aurait fait de son
quinquennat elle a pas fait du tout ça
est là je pense pas su incarner
suffisamment le son contenu maintenant
il ya des choses intéressantes même sur
le fond justement là j'ai parlé de la
forme je vais parler du fond bon je vais
pas parler du grand déclassement ou du
grand placement puisqu'elle s'est
expliquée dessus mais elle parle d'une
nouvelle france 1 c'est un peu le
concept de valérie pécresse et ça m'a
fait furieusement penser à quelque chose
qui remontent pour les plus anciens qui
s'appelait la nouvelle société de
jacques chaban delmas alors c'est assez
marrant parce que si la nouvelle france
répond d'une certaine manière à la
nouvelle société de jacques chaban
delmas ça manque pas de sel quand même
d'avoir une chiraquienne pur jus puisque
valérie pécresse se réclament du chirac
est pas nicolas sarkozy ça manque pas de
sel de voir quelques elle s'engouffre
dans ce concept alors que chaban delmas
évidemment a toujours
c'est toujours opposé à comme héritier
du gaullisme jacques chirac alors vers
ip création on l'a vu elles sont
expliquées certes mais enfin il court un
petit peu après sa droite évidemment
marine le pen eric zemmour qui sont dans
les sondages est en tout cas eric
zemmour jubile et capitalise sur les
déboires de valérie pécresse oui alors
il faudra voir les premiers sondages qui
ne vont pas tarder peut-être à tomber
demain ou après demain après ce fameux
meeting du zénith à paris pour valérie
pécresse mais moi j'ai eu le sentiment
en écoutant vers les presse elle a eu
des phrases extrêmement forte par
exemple une marianne ne peut pas être
voilées ce sont des thématiques
évidemment que qu'eric zemmour met sur
la table régulièrement moi j'ai eu
l'impression qu'elle essayer d'installer
une sorte de nouvelle primaire il ya eu
la primaire les républicains qui ont
départagé qui ont permis à vergt et
pécresse d'énergie j'ai l'impression à
tort quelques l installer une nouvelle
primaire avec eric zemmour avec les
thématiques d'eric zemmour alors je ne
suis pas certain que pour son électorat
notamment le plus centriste ce soit
bénéfique et qu'elle en tire davantage
de pourcentage dans les sondages mais ça
illustre quoi en réalité ça illustre la
difficulté qu'a valérie pécresse depuis
qu'elle a été désignée comme candidate
des républicains a à la fois jouer avec
son aile droite celle qu'incarne eric
ciotti le député des alpes-maritimes et
à donner des gages également à des gens
qui sont plus centriste oubliez pas qu
il l a eu l'appui de l'ue dit le parti
de jean christophe lagarde qui est un
parti officiellement centriste donc en
fait cette espèce de grand écart
permanent l'obligera à être extrêmement
souple est ce que ça lui permettra de de
ramasser très large rien n'est moins sûr
maintenant est ce qu'on a besoin d'eux
comme elle le dit d'être une grande
oratrice pour gagner une élection
présidentielle vous souvenez sans doute
de ce meeting d'emmanuel macron où ils
s'égosillait la voix éraillée à dire
c'est notre projet alors il avait un
magnétisme avec la salle emmanuel macron
qu'elle n'a sans doute pas eu au zénith
valérie pécresse mais en tout cas on
peut se poser la question maintenant sur
le programme il ya des choses
intéressantes me semble-t-il pour
valérie pécresse mais l'un des juges de
paix ce sera évidemment le ou les
premiers sondages qui vont tomber hélas
si elle décroche alors attention parce
que marine le pen eric zemmour qui sont
en embuscade pourrait en profiter et
puis qu'est ce qui va se passer dans les
jours qui viennent vous le verrez sans
doute une partie des élus peut-être les
républicains vont rejoindre emmanuel
macron parce que les plus centristes
considérons qu'elle a un discours trop
fort et au contraire peut-être que les
plus à droite chez les républicains
parmi les élus rejoindront au contraire
le camp d'eric zemmour ou de marine le
pen donc elle est sur la corde raide
c'est un moment compliqué mais qu'elle a
assumé ce matin sur une radio en disant
moi j'ai une pudeur et à cause ou grâce
à cette pudeur je ne m'exprime pas comme
vous avez l'habitude qu'on s'exprime
comme dirait un confrère d'une autre
chaîne la plus proche de mer quelques de
johnny hallyday peut-être valérie
pécresse de zemmour et eric zemmour
décidément la cible de toutes les
critiques avec parfois même des
dérapages à gauche celui de yannick
jadot
oui c'est clairement un dérapage yannick
jadot crédit sur une sur une radio ce
week-end qu'eric zemmour était le juif
de service qui servait l'antisémitisme
moi je pense que c'est une déclaration
antisémite le juif de service ça renvoie
dans le lexique français à des moments
quand même extrêmement sombres de notre
histoire et j'ajoute parce qu'il faut
essayer d'être objectif que si une
personnalité femme ou homme de droite
avait employé ce titre de ce type de
slogans à l'encontre d'eric zemmour ou
de quelqu'un d'autre je pense que la
levée de bouclier médiatique aurait été
beaucoup plus importante alors je ne dis
pas comme disent les jeunes que c'est
pas ces crèmes parce que yannick jadot à
mon avis a regretté ce qu'il avait dit
mais en tout cas ça n'a pas soulevé
l'exaspération à laquelle on pouvait
s'attendre
devant de telles déclarations et en
attendant le boulevard toujours pour
emmanuel macron alors boulevard pour
emmanuel macron
il y a quand même des petit caillou dans
sa chaussure vous parler depuis tout à
l'heure de la crise ukrainienne le
président
mais le président de la république est
revenu de son tête à tête de 5h30 avec
la nuire poutine en étant persuadé qu'il
avait obtenu la désescalade si par
un revers de l'histoire les choses
dégénérer en ukraine eh bien je pense qu
emmanuel macron ne serait pas
extrêmement comptable est content du
bilan qui devrait défendre sur cette
parenthèse diplomatique
donc c'est bien de jouer les matamores
et et les chefs d'état qui incarne et
qui veulent en imposer aux autres mais
si ça tourne court alors ce qui pouvait
être un avantage pour lui va s'avérer
peut-être dans les jeux qui viennent une
grande complication politique et puis je
reparle de valérie pécresse pour
terminer stéphanie
il faut voir aussi qu'il ya toute une
stratégie politique est en train de se
mettre en place que j'entends beaucoup
alors c'est du bas bruit pour l'instant
mais j'entends beaucoup de gens de
gauche qui estime que pour reconstruire
la gauche la meilleure des solutions ce
serait que valérie pécresse soit élu
qu'elle incarne le camp de droite
républicaine et cette petite musique là
n'est pas inintéressante parce qu'on a
une partie de l'électorat de gauche qui
est testé et qui dit oui pourquoi pas
voter valérie pécresse dont vous voyez
il peut y avoir beaucoup d'ingrédients
dans cette campagne tant que le chef de
l'état sortant et n'y est pas rentré on
va on attendra que les morceaux du
puzzle se mettent en place réellement
mais vous savez parfois les stratégies
politiques sont très compliquée à
décrypter et aboutissent le jour venu le
jour j à des surprises qu'on n'avait pas
vu venir effectivement on en a déjà et
merci beaucoup et ricker est d'avoir été
avec nous merci pour votre décryptage
est resté avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du pass
vaccinale et la question des libertés
dans notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français nous irons la rencontre aucun
qui s'épanchait sur l'instauration de la
vaccination en france alors le temps est
il venu de lâcher la bride faut-il
restaurer nos libertés on en débattra
dans quelques instants
[Musique]
vous avez lancé des appels à la
mobilisation notamment pour pour bloquer
des ponts mais vous avez été arrêtés
qu'est ce qui s'est passé j'ai été
arrêté pour complot incitations d'un
acte criminel et terroriste
c'est pas la première fois qu au québec
un bon arrêt était bloqué mais dans les
mesures que nous sommes en ce moment
sanitaire est très autoritaire du
gouvernement
je crois qu'ils ont voulu démontrer
qu'ils avaient la force d'autorité il ya
une volonté aussi peut-être de
discréditer tous tous ces mouvements
anti mesures sanitaires on sabre dames a
mis à l'écart ici au québec et au canada
très excité c'est d'avoir un dépôt
public
vous avez bouleversé un peu les codes la
de la pâtisserie moi je sentais que
j'avais beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de créativité en moi
et qu'il allait être compliqué
d'attendre mon tour j'ai re questionner
en fait la pâtisserie quand on achète
pâtissiers ont nourris ont fait plaisir
là par la gourmandise par la beauté mais
on nourrit aussi donc pour moi le verbe
nourrir n'était pas assez bien respecté
la pâtisserie c'est le dessert et que le
des soeurs
c'est à la fin la carte est la légèreté
est absolument à maîtriser puisqu'on
veut du coup un dessert qu'ils soient
gourmand mais aussi très léger qui
viennent ponctuer un très bon dîner
battrai pour moi c'est c'est beau c'est
bon et cela doit être également fin
parce que l'idée est le pari que je fais
c'est de se faire plaisir en se faisant
du bien
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
paul biya cumule plus de 39 ans de
pouvoir à la tête du cameroun à quelles
sont ses intentions pour 2025 tout le
monde sait qui aura un après biya mais
tous ceux qui sont autour du président
biya font comme si ça n'existera jamais
on a l'impression que la direction de
notre pays c'est un peu comme l'onu tout
le monde sait que ça existe tout le
monde sait qu'on est membre mais
personne n'y croit vraiment au cameroun
nous nous battons qu'en europe pour
l'avènement de la démocratie alors on
associe le cameroun à la françafrique
mais aussi à la corruption je pense
qu'on détourne plus d'argent que le
budget d'investissement de la république
par année et chez nous nous disons que
le poisson pourrit par la tête
[Musique]
chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes pieds
coup politique n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité
des idées courageuse des mots qui
comptent là en soi vient des murs passe
aujourd'hui une gauche qui est
extrêmement sujet mais la menace
écologique
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire les convois de la liberté
veulent désormais gagné strasbourg pour
dire non aux restrictions sanitaires et
manifestations étaient interdites aux
abords du parlement européen tous les
axes routiers menant vers la capitale
alsacienne sont aussi sous surveillance
après paris des milliers de voitures ont
rallié aujourd'hui bruxelles on y
retrouvera notre envoyé spécial david
tait lifar aux instants
et l'autre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français nous irons à la rencontre d'un
avocat qui s'est penché sur
l'instauration de la vaccination en
france jean marc andré estime que de
nombreuses libertés ont été bafoués au
nom de la crise sanitaire alors le temps
est il venu de lâcher la bride faut-il à
restaurer nos libertés on attend vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme verte
et france
[Musique]
les convois de la liberté votre donc
rallier strasbourg pour dire non aux
restrictions sanitaires des centaines de
véhicules qui étaient ces dernières
heures à bruxelles on y retrouve notre
reporter david à khalifa bonsoir david
certains convoyeurs donc de la liberté
ont pris la direction de strasbourg
d'autres devraient le faire dans les
prochaines heures
effectivement est ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que ce soir l'engouement espéré a
été plutôt moindre ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'hier à lille où plus de 1300
véhicules ont été signalés par les
forces de l'ordre et bien certains ont
pris la route de strasbourg d'autres
celle de bruxelles ait d'autres encore
celle de leur domicile d'où une
mobilisation tronquée dispatcher un
manque d'organisation également
responsable de cette fin en eau de
boudin ce matin le maire de la ville
belge estimait le nombre de véhicules à
400 ou 500 plus d'une trentaine ont été
interceptés il avait prévenu qu'aucun un
blocage ne sera tolérée c'est plus ou
moins ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
dans la capitale belge qui a interdit
cette mobilisation le dispositif de
sécurité a été renforcée les convoyeurs
de la liberté se sont réunis une
première fois place sainte catherine en
début d'après midi les forces de l'ordre
sont intervenues et diatement à noter
plusieurs arrestations et quelques
échauffourées le rassemblement a
rapidement été dispersés mais à ce
moment apprécié bien la motivation était
toujours dans les rangs écoutez
je passe à l'inter n'a aucune raison
d'être pour vous pour moi mes enfants et
pour qu'on arrive tout ça parce que là
ça n'a pu le vaccin n'a plus lieu d'être
c'est qu'un qr codes qu'on va voir nous
allons vivre que comme ça maintenant on
nous parle du passeport à la chinoise
regarder les rapports du sénat en france
c'est déjà écrit c'est déjà prêt y'a
plus qu'à mettre en application non on
est contre tous à retrouver ce que nous
avions avant quoi pouvoir les boire un
café vous et moi sans avoir besoin de
présenter un qr code aller faire ses
courses normalement
voilà je pense que beaucoup de gens sont
concernés je vois peu de monde bouge et
c'est triste mais cela va aller plus
vite qu'on ne le croit on veut
simplement que ça s'arrête pour
reprendre une vie normale en changeant
quelques règles par contre que tous ceux
qui nous gouvernent les corons plus haut
depuis cinq jours payés de ce qu'ils ont
fait surtout s'habiller en liberté pour
venir ici pour défendre nos droits le
droit à l'information le droit de la
santé à choisir le traitement qui nous
est donnée pas une obligation qui est
discriminante mais en europe on est
censé être en démocratie
d'accord on est censé vivre libre et là
on est victime de lois liberticides et
dites vous que sinon on est là c'est
clairement on est des citoyens qui
étaient à ce nous étions à insérer dans
la société nous accomplissions et nous
accomplissons encore nos devoirs et on
nous enlève nos droits donc on doit
continuer à se battre et clairement on
est des milliers et des milliers et s'il
faut continuer on continuera ça fait
sept mois en france qu'on est dans les
rues il pleut et neige et y vante les
gens ils sont tous dans les rues ils
arrivent ils sont la bise aux lèvres
tout à l'heure on se connaît tous on une
communauté tellement énorme c'est la
plus grande erreur qu'ils ont fait c'est
politique vous avez fait cette grande
erreur vous nous avez réuni et
aujourd'hui on est éveillée on est des
êtres qui ont une intelligence
collective qui allons le diffuser aux
autres qui le faisant de plus en plus au
fur et à mesure des mois suite à ce
premier rassemblement est bien là les
manifestants ont ensuite tenté de se
rapprocher de la commission européenne
mais là encore la police est intervenue
rapidement plusieurs personnes
interpellées certaines de manière assez
musclé et enfin une dernière tentative a
eu lieu ici un place du luxembourg non
loin de la commission là les autorités
se sont montrées pull plus virulente
quelques gaz lacrymogènes ont été tirés
sains les canons à eau utilisée de
manière partielle ce qui a à disperser
définitivement les manifestants qui se
sont retrouvés de manière assez
sporadiques dans des bars comme vous
pouvez le voir derrière moi et qu'ils
poursuivent pour certains encore une
fois ce convoi de la liberté alors
maintenant comme je vous le disais un
une possible action est prévue demain à
strasbourg plusieurs convois de tente de
rallier le parlement européen afin
d'interpeller les euro députés en
commission jusqu'à jeudi mais là aussi
est la préfète du bas-rhin était très
clair un josiane chevalier a pris un
arrêté interdisant toute manifestation
non déclarée dès qu'on vend qui passe et
vaccinales la préfète a donné des
consignes de fermeté comme ici les
forces de l'ordre pourront verbaliser et
interpeller les contrevenants vous
l'aurez compris à la fin de ce périple
du du convoi de la liberté a été
entachée quelque peu par une certaine
répression policière merci david khalifa
et le pass vaccinale qu'en pensent les
français nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de jean marc andré il est
avocat au barreau de versailles très
remonté contre la mise en place du pass
vaccinale il a rejoint un groupe d'une
trentaine d'avocats dans les yvelines
pour défendre les libertés individuelles
et mise en place du pass sanitaires il y
a quelques mois devenu le pass vaccinale
a été un véritable déclic pour lui il a
surtout peur que ça ne s'arrête pas là
reportage katia technique s'est mise à
gries
dans ce contexte de pandémie de nombreux
français se plaignent de la privation de
liberté individuelle et certains avocats
également l'on remarqué c'est pourquoi
je vais à la rencontre aujourd'hui de
jean marc andré avocat à versailles
ancien bâtonnier de versailles bonjour m
comment allez vous non merci certains
français se plaignent on a pu le voir
encore une fois alors des convois de la
liberté et vous ça vous fait réagir ah
ben je pense que le mouvement du convoi
de la liberté dans le prolongement de ce
que nous vivons depuis bientôt deux ans
c'est à dire qu'à un moment les gens se
sont réveillés ont vu qu'il y avait eu
mensonge sûrement change que les choses
ce conte
l'antenne de sanitaires n'étaient pas
vraiment sanitaire qu'il y avait quand
même un marqueur politique voire
plusieurs marqueurs politiques dans tout
ce qu'on a subi tant qu'homme de loi
vous vous intéressez aussi au respect du
droit will complètement c'est à dire que
la loi du 5 août suite aux annonces du
président de la république le 12 juillet
ont été les prémices de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le fait que les français
sont privés de leur liberté naturelle
leurs libertés fondamentales de se
déplacer d'aller et venir de pouvoir
avoir une vie la plus normale possible
alors que dans le même temps aucune loi
n'impose la vaccination obligatoire donc
on est arrivés dans un système de droit
on prive des citoyens de droits
fondamentaux je rappelle que les hommes
naissent et demeurent libres et égaux en
droits alors que pourtant il ne viole
aucune loi qui ne commettent strictement
aucune infraction
que ça vous a donné envie de vous
mobiliser a complètement mais je me suis
sentie très seule et j'attendais
naïvement peut-être mais j'attendais
parce que la profession d'avocat si on
ne bouge pas lorsqu'il ya une atteinte
aux libertés même infime soit elle pas
si nous ne bougeons pas personne ne
bougera alors je me suis dis bah il va
prendre le taureau par les cornes on va
créer un groupe de travail est d'auxonne
montbard haut avec des confrères qui
partagent la même vision que moi ça a
permis déjà de sortir de cette solitude
pour revenir en convoi de la liberté
c'est ça aussi c'est un permis de
prendre conscience aux gens qu'on
n'était pas des pestiférés parce qu'on
n'était pas vaccinée ou parce qu'on
n'avait pas un schéma vaccinal complet
aussi puisque comme j'aime le dire les
vaccinés d'aujourd'hui sont les lots
vacciner de demain et on sait très bien
que le 15 février beaucoup vont perdre
leur pass vaccinale donc voilà on a créé
ce groupe de travail ont réfléchi sur
les textes parce que avocats comme
magistrat ce sont des textes nouveaux
qu'il a fallu intégrer alors aujourd'hui
maître vous défendez des personnes qui
hier ont subi les restrictions au
premier chef leur travail puisque
certains malheureusement ne sont pas
licenciés puisque la loi ne le prévoit
pas mais sont suspendus ce qui
finalement est une solution encore pire
pour eux puisque c'est sans délai ils ne
savent pas jusqu'à quand ils n'ont pas
de revenus et après effectivement c'est
pour eux la perte de 2 to le tout leur
espoir parce que finalement il va
falloir trouver un autre travail et sans
être indemnisées par pôle emploi parce
qu'il n'y a pas de chômage puisque c'est
une suspension du contrat de travail
comment la justice réagit-elle dans ces
cas là parce que tous n'ont pas gain de
cause wheeler pour nous avocats entre
guillemets de terrain quand on n'est pas
dans le conseil constitutionnel eut le
conseil d'état mais devant les premiers
juges on sait que c'est très difficile
parce qu'il faut amener les dossiers
sans démons sans essayer de faire
comprendre que c'est un combat politique
ce n'est pas un combat politique est un
combat juridique et c'est aussi très
compliqué pour les magistrats quel qu'il
soit d'appréhender de juger ce genre de
contentieux et de dossiers parce que
bien évidemment il ya leur propre
ressenti par rapport à la vaccination
qui chez eux comme chez tout le monde
prend une place énorme puisque à travers
eux c'est leur famille c'est leur
enfance et leur parole en grands parents
donc ils ont forcément une idée une
conception par rapport à la vaccination
au pas par rapport à la suspension des
personnels ou des personnes qui viennent
devant eux donc c'est difficile de
garder une certaine forme d'objectivité
dans le dossier mais certains y arrivent
on y arrive est ce que la parole
politique à la contribuent à alimenter
ce clivage selon vous à bâle à alimenter
parce qu'en fait la parole politique
aujourd'hui est devenue la source de
droit voire la règle de droit
c'est-à-dire que dès le 12 juillet les
gens étaient persuadés alors que la loi
n'était pas encore voté que les
restrictions ont été mises en place que
le pass and i ter été mis en place alors
que rien été voté et c'est ça qui est
aujourd'hui compliqué c'est à dire que
on écoute la parole des ministres la
parole du président de la république
dont vous rêvez toute puissance du
politique et finalement le législatif
passe au second plan et malheureusement
les débats que nous avons eus à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat n'ont
pas été à la hauteur de nos attentes on
voit bien que les amendements finalement
n'ont pas été discutés comme il l'aurait
dû être tout a été fait
j'allais dire dans un délai très court
très rapide très contraint toujours sur
des périodes de vacances on qu'on prenne
le temps de se poser voilà je pense
qu'on a été trop loin et qu'il est temps
aujourd'hui que tout cela cesse mais sur
des conditions qui seront effectivement
à redéfinir et avoir sur un plan
politique et ça je pense que ce sera le
travail de la nouvelle assemblée qui
sera élu au printemps prochain mais jean
marc andrey attendons que des
engagements plus forts de la part des
candidats sur ce thème il faut dire que
le maintien du pass vaccinale préoccupe
beaucoup de français on a pu encore le
voir ce week-end avec la mobilisation du
convoi pour la liberté d'où cette
question le temps est il venu de lever
des restrictions faut-il restaurer nos
libertés c'est l'objet de notre face à
face
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler france 4 9
délégué départemental du modem dans nord
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur ce
plateau philippe bouriat qui conseiller
régional écologiste en ile-de-france
bonsoir philippe rien qui merci d'être
avec nous alors une réaction tout
d'abord à ce témoignage à convient
d'entendre cet avocat qui a 20 ans de
droit derrière lui considère que le pass
vaccinale est une atteinte aux libertés
individuelles c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup d'avocats qui partagent cette
pensée france quatreboeufs emmanuel
macron à rogner dans la liberté des
premiers pardon la liberté des français
vous comprenez un certain agacement est
en tout cas dont on peut sur le plan
juridique et pas nécessairement
politique
et leur bonsoir à vous tout à coup vous
m'avez donné un petit coup de vieux
permettez moi de vous le dire puisque
j'ai trente trois ans d'enseignement en
faculté de droit et je me sens donc un
sage et le sage
vous que bien sûr et j'ai déjà dit
plusieurs fois votre antenne les mesures
qui sont prises
réduisent nos libertés bien évidemment
mais pour autant je pense que nous en
sommes tous d'accord elles ont été
prises c'est vrai avec une sorte de
précipitation mais la situation le
justifiait lorsque le bâtonnier andré
dit que l'assemblée nationale n'a pas
suffisamment discuté mais écouter
lorsque vous êtes dans une situation
d'urgence
on ne peut pas non plus discuter pendant
des semaines ou des mois et laisser
passer les décès avant de se demander
comment soigner les morts
alors oui il y a eu des mesures qui ont
restreint aux libertés oui elle était
indispensable
et oui je pense et françois bayrou l'a
dit lorsqu'il y aura moins
d'hospitalisations
il faudra sérieusement penser
effectivement
évidemment et c'est bien naturel a
recouvré la liberté le conseil consiste
constitutionnel a visé un équilibre
qu'on appelle le bilan coût avantage il
y avait plus davantage que de coups à
restreindre provisoirement de liberté et
il y aura bien sûr
une nécessité urgente de les recouvrer
dès que la situation sera apaisée
assainis ou un peu normalisée philippe
bourrier tir vous êtes aussi clément
qu'en france 4e bof
on a rogné nos libertés écoutez je j'ai
noté une phrase assez drôle soigner les
morts quand ils sont morts on a tous
besoin de l'espagne est bien évidemment
et je pense qu'ils voulaient dire
prévenir plutôt que de soigner nos mains
il ya quelque chose qui est très simple
monsieur le délégué et moi même je pense
que tous les deux nous sommes pas
médecins il y avait une organisation une
petite organisation en dirons nous qui
s'appelle l' oms dans son mondial de la
santé et puis on a un petit truc qui
s'appelle le le comité scientifique que
vos
vos responsables parce que là du coup là
mais je me retrouve en marge et je me
retrouve plus et non par en marche
ne consulte pas le ms ainsi que le
recueil des scientifiques ne recommande
pas la vaccination obligatoire et se
passe vaccinale est une ligne sans
langue c'est le ministre votre ministre
de la santé qui nous l'a dit c'est une
obligation déguisée de vacciner les gens
alors vaccinés oui nous sommes pour les
écologistes dès le départ d'ailleurs je
le rappelle que yannick jadot bien avant
que le vaccin soit disponible a été le
premier est décriée par tout le monde y
compris par vos rangs nous sommes pour
une vaccination
vaccination veut dire une protection
intégrale vous ne pouvez pas être
contaminé et vous ne pouvez pas
contaminer les autres actuellement nous
donne un booster à pour remettre les
choses bien en place j'ai ma dose de
rappel parce que sinon c'est une mort
sociale comme à pul l'annoncé le
bâtonnier et aujourd'hui j'ai une pensée
sincère pour ces millions de français
demain qui vont se retrouver sur le
carreau et votre clémence votre
gentillesse par rapport à des gens qui
agissons urgence qui avait quand même
plus d'un an et neuf mois de recul pour
pouvoir intervenir donc lorsqu'on agit
en urgence comme ça ça s'appelle de
l'amateurisme et l'amateurisme
aujourd'hui va mettre des millions de
français et de françaises sur le chaos
demain monsieur alors faut-il restaurer
nos libertés vous allez nous dire oui
c'est la question en tout cas que l'on
vous pose ce soir et une première
réaction d'agnès agnès qui nous dit
toutes ces restrictions n'ont aucun but
sanitaires bien sûr que nous devons
retrouver notre liberté par la force
s'il le faut franz 80 comment vous jugez
ce genre de sortie parce que c'est vrai
qu'à nier c'est pas la seule il ya plein
de français qui estiment que ben voilà
le but il n'était pas vraiment
sanitaires il était davantage politique
vous dites c'est la théorie du complot
ou vous comprenez ce ce genre finalement
de sentiment qu'ont certains français
alors trois choses la première j'ai
vraiment d'y soigner les morts je
voulais dire par l'action n'avait pas
réagi on aurait plus que des morts et
qu'on n'aurait pas pu les soigner la
deuxième oui l'organisation mondiale de
la santé a préconisé un certain nombre
de mesures et parmi lesquels je rappelle
qu'au début de la crise elle disait que
le masque n'était pas indispensable et
le gouvernement de ce point de vue lui a
fait confiance peut être avec un léger
excès d'optimisme la troisième je
comprends l'exaspération
je ne pense pas que ce soit du
complotisme je pense en revanche qu'il
ya un certain nombre de personnes qui ne
font pas confiance au suffrage universel
et qui ne sont pas prêts à accepter des
décisions qui sont prises par un pouvoir
élu démocratiquement et je constate
d'ailleurs que ces personnes ne font pas
confiance non plus à l'élection qui
vient entre de madame artaud à monsieur
zemmour il ya quand même un champ
politique assez large
chacun peut trouver à s'exprimer dans
deux mois donc moi ce que je leur dise
et si vous n'êtes pas contents et
j'accepte tout à fait que vous ne soyez
pas contents et bien voter voter pour
des adversaires du pouvoir actuel mais
envisager plus le vote que la réaction
violente et ainsi nous pourrons
continuer de vivre en paix tout même une
petite question à parce qu'on va passer
aussi la parole à un sénateur qui va
nous rejoindre dans quelques instants en
direct aujourd'hui certes la france fait
partie des pays qui prévoit des
allégements les bars les transports les
stades les discothèques mais
paradoxalement dur s'il passe vaccinale
à la dose de rappel sera
lisez ou plus tard quatre mois après la
fin du schéma vaccinal initiale jusqu'à
sept mois jusqu'ici france quattro veuve
tout de même est ce que c'est justifié
alors qu'on sait tous voilà
malheureusement ait encore des gens qui
sont hospitalisés on ne va pas dire le
contraire ici mais on sait tous de la
comique rond il ya un peu moins de
danger que le vaccin n'a pas
nécessairement été des plus efficaces
comme l'ont dit les scientifiques est-ce
que c'est toujours justifier le maintien
de ce pass vaccinale aujourd'hui
alors vous me posez la question à moi
qui ai reçu ma troisième dose à saint
malo cet après midi ça va nous a embêtés
dans le fond ben oui mais je peux vous
confirmer que cela m'a embêté que je les
fais parce que j'allais perdre mon pass
vaccinale mais que je effet aussi parce
que je pense que malgré tout ce vaccin
réduit la gravité des cas et bien sûr
qu'il faudra supprimer le pass vaccinale
mais pour l'instant il reste encore de
très nombreux de nos concitoyens qui
sont hospitalisés et je pense que on
peut encore tenir un mois deux mois
avant en de recouvrer la liberté d'aller
boire un verre ça n'est quand même pas
nous avons conservé contrairement à ce
que dit le bâtonnier andré la liberté
d'aller et venir reste entière la
liberté de culte reste entière on nous a
quand même pas prise et donne tous nos
droits fondamentaux même pas d'ailleurs
de nos droits notre pays heureusement
mais je suis d'accord avec vous mais il
nous reste deux mois avant de retourner
boire un verre écoutez ce sera tenable
car c'est à des élections tient alors ça
ça compte ça gronde aussi à du côté lr
20 sénateurs les républicains appellent
à lever le pinceau vaccinale sans délai
je propose de regarder voilà cette
infographie nous sommes vingt sénateurs
à l'air dont je fais partie qui ont
refusé de voter le passé ni terre
vaccinale pardon qui demande son arrêt
sans délai notre tribune collective est
paru aujourd'hui dans le figaro
justement va être connectés dans
quelques instants avec est là où percent
éditeurs et l'est de la côte d'or l'un
des auteurs de cette tribune bonsoir
alain houpert merci d'être avec nous
vous dites vous le pass vaccinale se
révèle être contreproductive ou demander
son arrêt immédiat
pourquoi ne pas suivre le calendrier
annoncé par le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent la levée du
pass vaccinale prévue pour fin mars
début avril s'il n'y a pas de nouvelle
vague ça fait trop loin pour vous
ça a été dit tout à l'heure le pas
solitaire et c'est pas une mesure
sanitaire le palatinat n'est pas une
mesure sanitaire c'est une mesure
politique est là la ficelle est très
gros saint-gabriel attal dit il
que la bonté du par la bonté du
gouvernement on va supprimer le pass
vaccinale quelques semaines avant les
élections
présidentielles déjà quand cette île de
l'état de l'épidémie on sait une chose
c'est qu'actuellement
l'épidémie on a parlé des morts ne pas
soigner des morts il ya peu de morts et
puis il ya surtout des morceaux sio
desmaures sociaux
cambo j'ai appelé mon directeur de 2 de
la sncf direct
30 % des tgv sont déprogrammés pourquoi
parce que les gens ne veulent plus aller
dans le train parce que beaucoup de gens
ne veulent pas de cette troisième dose
et se passe vaccinale est faussement
rassurant on l'a l'om est ce le l'om est
cela dit l'om est ce qui est un
organisme international l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui avec des grands
spécialistes qui ont quand même pris
beaucoup d'autres q parce que cette
maladie maintenant on l'a connu on n'est
pas
on a gagné quelques années sur la
connaissance de sa maladie on la connaît
et on sait que ce vaccin ne protège pas
de de la contamination et ne protège pas
de la propagation et si on veut vraiment
impasse sanitaire il faudrait une
impasse par test serait plus logique et
se placent vaccinale il donne il rassure
faussement
les gens qui sont vaccinés qui sont dans
ce parcours vaccinale en se disant je
suis totalement
indemne de tout danger de vaccination je
indemne de deux secondes le danger
pardonnez moi vous dit en gros le
gouvernement doit arrêter je cite je
vous cite d'emmerder les français avec
des mesures politicienne il faut donc
élever se passe clairement
comme comme ils l'ont fait aux états
unis comme au royaume-uni pardon comme
ils l'ont fait comme ils l'ont fait au
danemark
souvenez-vous le royaume le royaume uni
c'est un des pays qui a été ré avec qui
serait de lens en israël ils sont en
train de reculer sur la quatrième dose
tout le monde est vacciné et
il ya une
en israël j'ai eu quelques coups de fil
de deux confrères israélien les hôpitaux
sont sous tension alors qu'en france les
les services de réanimation ne sont pas
ne sont pas surchargées et des gens qui
sont en rénovation ce sont des gens
qu'on décore comorbidités et se passe
vaccinale c'est un fourre tout où on
veut tous vaccinés et c'est une manière
pour le gouvernement de dire qu'il a
raison le gouvernement a misé sur le
tout vaccin et c'est une erreur une
maladie il ya plusieurs façon de la
traiter le vaccin en fait partie et le
gouvernement a divisé les français en
mettant les gens qui sont contre le pass
vaccinale en les faisant passer pour des
anti vaccin ce qui est complètement faux
on aidera à laon père oui mais je pars
je pars je parle en tant que
parlementaire je parle en tant que
parlementaire ma connaissance médicale
m'a justement permis d'avoir des
contacts avec des chercheurs avec des
chercheurs qui ne sont pas du médecin
parce qu'un médecin c'est quoi c'est un
prescripteur c'est quelqu'un qui fait ce
qu'on lui dit c'est sûr qui fait ce
qu'on peut ce n'est pas un chercheur
j'ai contacté des chercheurs qui a
qui sont les plus à même de nous de nous
renseigner et moi on arrive à la fin de
ce débat et au vote a en tout cas donné
la parole on voulait vous vous la donne
et je vais quand même laissé répondre
également philippe bourrier acquis merci
en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous à nous
avoir apporté
également votre opinion sénateur a l'air
de côte-d'or philippe briat qui vous est
sur la même ligne stricte dallas et où
le père parce que ce discours peuron
choqué aussi certain du tout c'est un
discours réaliste je remercie monsieur
le sénateur de sa clairvoyance voyez
pourtant on n'est pas de la même
obédience et on peut
lorsque les choses vont dans le bon sens
les saluer oui c'est un coup politique
c'est un excellent coup politique avec
le timing croyable orchestré avec une
main de deux mètres disant voilà deux
semaines avant le premier tour nous
allons lever le pass vaccinale les
masques etc enfin on a l'impression
d'être dans une série au lieu d'y aime
moi je voudrais dire une chose aux
délégués du modem c'est un conclure
effectif qui soutire énormément ce ce
cette privation de droits cette
privation de liberté personne ne s'est
offusqué chez vous lorsque le président
de la république a refusé en russie de
faire un test pcr personnes pourtant
c'est la base le président poutine avait
tout à fait raison de demander à ce que
le présent la république fasse un test
de pc alors maintenant j'entends alors
les complotistes c'est plutôt les gens
du gouvernement non c'est pour éviter
que le présent la république ou que les
russes puissent avoir l'adn du président
mais de qui vous moquez en disant ça les
services secrets français le groupe de
ses côtés je présente à public ne peut
pas récupérer les échantillons le ts
juste après de qui on se moque alors on
veut faire passer le président poutine
pour un grand despote mais ici en france
on a aussi le nôtre et je suis pas sûr
que le président poutine avait tort en
demandant une choses basiques celle de
faire un test pcr donc testons des gens
permettant que les tests soient gratuits
et là on aura une vraie cartographie de
ce qui se passe donc assumer votre
responsabilité assumée votre désordre
assumez votre lacunes assumer d'avoir
envoyé des blindés devant des citoyens
français qui demandait à avoir la
liberté et augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
on leur a envoyé des blindés et je
remercie votre rédaction d'avoir été
présent sur les champs-elysées et
partout en france pour montrer la
véracité et pas des chaînes prom acronis
qui ont essayé de nous désinformer
pendant tout ce temps la france quoi toi
battre le mois de la fin rapide on est
déjà à la fin du débat depuis une minute
mais allez-y des choses la première je
pense que le chef d'état étranger qui
mettra un coteau dans le nez du
président poutine n'est pas né et de la
même manière un président de la
république n'a pas se permettre un coton
dans le nez lorsqu'ils visitent un pays
étranger c'est une question de
l'espace avec son staff médical vous
n'êtes pas nous dire que représente la
applique n'a pas un staff médical qui
l'accompagnent 24 sur un canal à rendre
sur sa santé envers un pays pas une
question de santé c'est une question de
protection
si vous avez bassiner pendant des mois
qu'il fallait se faire tester alertée la
protéger car et lorsque le président
poutine il est dans son droit il devance
les pays vous dire ici et bien de
réussir on se fait tester notre refusé
de le faire c'est vraiment ce qu'on
allait vous nous obligez nous mais par
contre on vous demande d'appliquer des
lois vous refuser de le faire venez
d'être congédié de votre parti politique
en raison de votre violence verbale ne
tentez pas selon l'influent cieux
monsieur monsieur je n'étais pas le test
de monsieur macro et lors de sa visite à
moscou mais voilà
s'agissant des blindés ce sont des
blindés de la gendarmerie
personnes d'admirer quand même et je
rappelle que lorsque l'arc de triomphe
n'étaient pas protégés on a vu dans quel
état il a fini la moindre des choses
c'est d'assurer tranquillement et sans
agressivité
le respect des personnes et des biens
c'est ce qui se fait dans un état de
droit et ça n'a pas été du tout exagéré
d'ailleurs n'y a pas eu de violence
particulière et je me réjouis de parts
comme d'autres ces deux matchs étaient
pas présents sur les champs-elysées vous
aurez des violences de quel côté
merci messieurs en tout cas averti si
l'idée était effectivement que vous ne
soyez pas forcément d'accord c'est c'est
le jeu du débat merci franz quatreboeufs
merci à philippe bouriat qui également
alain houpert qui nous a rejoints dans
ce débat merci et c'est la fin de cette
émission se retrouve à 20 heures ou
demain pour une nouvelle émission
n'oubliez pas de réagir d'ici là à
l'actualité continue
[Musique]
en 2010 il y avait environ 200
satellites en orbite en 2021 on en
compte